I'm gonna oh my god.
There's no intro.
I'm sorry.
I'm tired
Everybody's oh my god, hello No intro whatsoever, we're just we're just going in Live from New York.
Okay, we're not in New York.
I've been watching SNL during this trip.
Okay, how's the mic?
Is the mic that bad?
Let me double check the mic real quick.
Oh my god I'm not okay right now.
I just need you to know that Where's my mic?
Why is it not?
Where's my mic?
I don't understand.
What am I using for my- it has to be this Okay, yeah, okay, no, it's the right mic, okay, I hope the mic is okay All right.
All right.
Okay.
So hello everybody Hello, I'm I'm tired.
I'm so tired right now Like I got home, oh, yeah, no, and I also got okay, so long story short, I'm in Japan and Somehow I managed to get food poisoning in Japan I don't know how how I've been so unlucky this entire trip, but like Somehow I managed to fucking get food poisoning in Japan
The last time I've ever got Food poisoning was when I was a child
It was bad it was so Bad the food poisoning.
I was gonna stream on that day, too which sucked even more and I'm Tom my gosh, and I missed the The concert that's gonna okay.
So for those who don't know, I am in Sapporo.
I was in Sapporo
For the Japan ALGS, so I'm okay talking about it now cuz it's over so like I For those who don't know what ALGS is it is the biggest eSport LAN event for APEX and A lot of my friends were like you have to if you want to experience LAN for the first time You have to go to Sapporo because it might be technically it might be the last best one.
So I'm not sponsored or anything or endorsed for anything.
So I was just like Shit, it might be the last best land and like After that just might just be downhill from there.
So like I should experience it before it's too late You know before before, you know You know before things go downhill.
I might as well experience the best LAN APEX has ever done because I have no point of reference because I never been to a LAN before and So like and like I don't never been to an APEX LAN before let alone any LAN before so everything was like wow To me cuz like So that's why that's why I'm here I do I don't know if like it was a good decision Because like I got food poisoning and a lot of shit happened I was not okay.
I was not okay yesterday.
I need you to know, um, I need you to know that I couldn't even keep liquids down.
Every time I tried to drink water, like, it was gone.
It was so bad.
I don't know how I was able to recover, like, in 24 hours.
I, like, was in bed since... I was in bed, like, the day before, starting at, like, 7 p.m., and then, like, I never got out of bed until...
Like, I mean, other than using the bathroom to, you know, fucking fix my food poisoning problem by expelling every goddamn thing in my mouth, um, in my stomach.
So, I was... I went to bed at 7 p.m.
because I was so tired, and maybe it was when the food poisoning was about to take effect, and I never got out of bed, other than, like, the use of the bathroom, until, like...
Oh, my God.
Until, like, maybe, like, 4 in the morning, the next... the day after.
So, like, today.
So, it was, like... Okay, so, like, I'm talking in, like, JST time right now, so, like, people in NA might be really confused, but I'm talking in JST time.
So, like, until, like, 4 a.m.
JST, because I need... I was like, sponsor time!
For reals or no, no.
I was, um, I was sponsored to do a Minecraft co-casting with Mintz, and, uh, so I was like, I gotta be better by then.
I was like, I was so worried, because I was like, I gotta be okay before this fucking sponsor, because it's gonna be awkward as hell.
Um, so I had to do a sponsor stream on Twitch, um, and, yeah, because, like, I had to be on Twitch, because Mintz was gonna be on YouTube, and, um, we had to have one person on Twitch and one person on YouTube, so I was the one that's gonna be on Twitch,
and I was just like, oh, my God, I gotta... So, I didn't exist for, like, at least 24 hours, uh, yesterday, because I was so fucked up.
Uh, hahahaha, it's... Oh, my God, I sounded like, uh, that's called being a professional.
Also, because I was a lot better.
Um, okay, so, I'm gonna give you, like, I'll, I'll post, like, photos, I'll show you guys photos and stuff when I'm actually back back, and not, like, on my laptop.
Um, but I did take a lot of photos.
In the past, I had to wait for, like, photo perms, like, you know, ask, like, we would have to, like, ask, like, um, stores or, like, places I was at and stuff like that to be, like, can we show this place and shit like that.
Now, I'm in... Now that I'll be back in NA, I'd be like, I can show this whenever I want.
Anyway, um, because I'm just a little indie.
Anyway, um, um, and anyway, so, like, um, okay, I'm gonna give you guys... How do I feel about Apex Land?
I went to watch on the first day and the last day.
Okay, that's a lot.
I went to watch on the first day and a little bit on the third day and then last day and then all the other days I was shopping.
Okay, so, like, um, I was shopping.
It's the portal.
Whoa!
Shopping!
Um, okay, so, um, the reason why is that I realized, I was like, okay, this is so fucked up.
Like, I traveled all the way here to experience my first ever land, but, like, I'm, I'm fucking, it's like my stream, I'm not sponsored.
I realized, land's not my thing.
I traveled away and I was like, I've never done land before.
I'm like, whoa, I wonder what that's like.
And then I traveled away and I was like, oh man, I don't think land's my thing.
I was like, I was just like, oh man.
I was like, oh, this is not as, not as exciting as I, I think it's cause, like, I don't have a team I'm rooting for, too.
I was just like, oh my god, look, there's my friends over there, my friends over there, and my friends over there.
Um, and then I was just like, oh man.
And I also was like, super incognito mode, too, because I was so fucking paranoid.
I did take a lot of secret photos, so like, and then, um, so like, I was just like, like, I didn't really have a team, team I'm explicitly rooting for.
I was just like, these are where all my friends team Fort was in, and stuff like that.
I, I did, like, in the finals, I rooted for Alliance, because it affects a Dragoon, so like, I was just sad, cause they were always, they always got, like, second place and stuff.
And so, um, the casting was so good.
I wouldn't know, I was at the venue, so I was listening to Japanese commentary, so I didn't, I wouldn't know, I didn't understand what they were saying.
I mean, I could have, like, I didn't want to pull up a stream to listen to English commentary while watching ALGS.
So, so like, I was just like, yeah, so I didn't know, guys.
Like, I had to, yeah, I was just watching it.
Um, so like, um, I, I, I mean, I did for, like, a little bit, but then I was like, this is stupid.
Like, I was like, I pulled up, like, B stream in the main channel, um, and like, to listen to a bit of the commentary, cause I was like, I don't know what's going on.
Like, I know what's going on, I'm, like, watching the gameplay, but I was just like, it's weird, it's like, I'm just, I feel like it's weird not listening to, like, casting I understand, because, like, you know, I don't understand Japanese, so I was like,
let me pull up English casting and just, um, just see how it works.
If, like, I put on my headphones and then let's, like, and pull up the stream and everything.
And then I was like, this is so fucking weird.
Like, I was like, that's so, it's so, that's so weird.
And then I was, like, wasting my phone's battery too, so I was just like, ah, I don't know.
I, I feel, like, fucking weird wasting my phone's battery as well.
And also, what's playing on the screen is not what's playing for, like, B-stream, because, you know, Wig's watching other people's POV.
So, like, I couldn't watch Wig's stream because he was fucking reacting to things that wasn't in front of me.
So I was like, I'm not gonna look at the B-stream while I'm here.
Like, I was like, I'm here.
Why the fuck am I watching my, like, my iPhone?
Just, I was just like, and then, like, you know, I could have, I could have also watched the main stream too as well, but it was just, it was weird, like, like, just listening on my headphones while, like, watching.
So I just, like, went, like, fuck it.
I'll just, okay, so, like, the reason why I was like, oh, maybe Lan's not for me, because maybe it was, okay, like, I even watched the, because, okay, I tested it out.
I, I, like, tested it out for, like, three different days to, like, make sure if, like, I enjoyed Lan.
Because, like, I was like, if I don't enjoy it, like, I won't say I didn't enjoy it, but if I wasn't like, oh, yeah, woo, great time for, like, any of the three days, then I know, like, Lan's not for me.
So, like, the first day, like, it was not, it was not packed, obviously, but, like, because, like, it was just, like, regular group st- yeah, I needed to confirm, it was a scientific method.
I was, it was a scientific method.
I'm sorry, I, you might heard a little burp, like, apparently, that's a food poisoning side effect, and I usually am able to restrain it, because I don't burp.
I usually go, like, bop, but, like, oh, my stomach is not okay.
I...
Anyway, okay, anyway, I usually don't burp.
I never burp, and now I'm, like, you are a woman, Toki, that is so, oh, my God, suppress your madly urge.
Anyway, so, um, first day, it was the group stages, and then, like, I don't know, I guess there was, like, no stakes involved, like, no, like, uh, no, like, uh, nothing, like, too intense or anything, so, like, it was, it was alright, like, it was long.
Oh, my God, I stayed the entire day, because I, you know, I was, like, first day, yay!
And then, like, at the end, I was just, like, oh, first day.
Because, like, I was, like, oh, man, I wanna know what that's like, you know, um, for the first day, so I was just, like, um, it was so long, it was, like, what, 12 games, and then there were so many, oh, my God, there were so many breaks, and, like, so many,
like, what's the word called?
Like, they had so many pauses and everything, and I was, like, oh, my God, how the, how do you, and then, like, I left in the middle of it, because there was, like, um, there was a place called Fan Zone, um, and it was, oh, yeah, like, intermission technical issues,
there were so many intermissions and technical issues, so I was just, like, oh, my God, like, ha!
Oh, my God, no, there wasn't, there was more than, oh, sorry, it wasn't even 12 games, it was 18 games, I left after the second set, I was, like, I couldn't watch the third set, I was just, like, I can't, I forgot there was another six games afterwards,
I was, like, it was 18 games, and I was just, like, I can't, I'm not strong enough for that.
And so, like, I, like, left after the second set, because I was just, like, oh, my God, there's too many games, and so, like, I think it's just, okay, so then I, like, I was mostly spending my time after, like, the first, like, during the first and second set,
like, I left during the first and second set to go to the Fan Area to, like, look around, like, the, you know, the merch and stuff, the merch and, like, the Fan Zone and stuff like that.
It was really cool, I'll show you guys photos and everything, and, like, oh, my God, it was crazy, Fnatic's line was, every other booth was, like, almost empty, and then Fnatic's merch booth line, this was first day, by the way, was, like, so long, it was literally,
like, like, it was looping, and, like, it was literally, like, the only line that was looping, and I felt so bad for them.
They had to look at Fnatic, yeah, because, like, they were literally on home turf, so, like, all the, um, all the JP, um, staff were, you know, not staff, JP people were there to support Fnatic and stuff.
Um, Powerball, thank you for the super chat, thank you, sorry if I can't read super chats, I literally, I'm just on my laptop, so it's even harder to look through, see it, but thank you so much.
Um, Saturday Night Everything went according to plan, but I still hope you enjoyed your trip, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Um, yeah, I still enjoyed it, my trip, but it was just to see, like, if I liked it, experience, like, if I was ever going to go to land again, and I don't know, I feel like, no?
I don't know, because, like, um, this, like, I don't know if I, maybe, like, in a couple years, maybe I'll try another land, but, like, I don't know, like, I felt like, if I didn't, like, I enjoyed it, but, like, I knew it was not going to happen.
Not for me, and I felt like if Apex couldn't do it for me, then, like, I just think, like, I just personally don't have, like, I just personally might not enjoy land, like, not enjoy land, but I might personally not, like, be a land person.
Um, maybe it's because I was also, like, by myself, too, so... I was so paranoid, I was so fucking... I actually, I even got into the player lounge, too, because I had, like, a special ticket, um, so, like, um, so I had access to, like, basically, like,
the places where players have access to, and I felt so...
Like, I didn't say hi to anybody, but I saw, like, I saw, like, everybody, like, there, like, all, like, the famous Apex players were just hanging out.
By the way, like, the lounge isn't, is not that, like, oh, my God, the lounge, it was not that fancy, it was literally just a room filled with players, and there was, like, a little, like, snack area, but apparently, from what they told me, from what my friends told me,
like, the food assortment, like, the free food was not great.
Because, like, it was, like, super greasy and made people, like, bloated and stuff, so, like, people were just, like, going for, like, konbini food and stuff like that, because, like, eating it was not, didn't feel so good during games.
So, like, um, so, like, people, they were just, like, yeah, it's not, not it, and stuff, like, not performance food.
Uh, so, like, yeah, that's why, like, I didn't eat any of the lounge food, because I was, like, when I looked at it, I was just, like, oh, it looks a lot, it looks, like, like, not, like, ugh, but, like, I was, like, oh, that looks a lot.
I did sneak a bread in.
I was just, like, going to cut my bread.
I was just, like, um, um, yeah, but I did was, um, and I saw, like, you know, I saw a lot of the famous players there.
I didn't say hi, but, like, I saw them.
I sneaked a photo of, like, a, like, the Dragoon plush in the player lounge, and, like, I'm pretty sure nobody recognized me.
I was just, I was, like, I was, like, and then I hit the Dragoon plushie instantly.
I was, like, oh, they don't know I'm a VTuber in your lounge right now.
I don't even belong here.
I'm not even a player.
I sneaked in a little quick photo.
Um, um, anyway, so, yeah, I felt like a stalker, not gonna lie, I really did.
Um, oh, my gosh, okay, so, like, uh, so, like I said, I also went to the third day.
I think it was the third day.
It was, which, yeah, it was the first elimination round.
I went to the first elimination round, and, like, it got a little better because, you know, teams were getting eliminated, but it was, like, I was just, like, it still didn't feel like, you know, stakes were there yet, and I just didn't feel, oh, so Sapporo was so fucking cold.
It not, it's not just, not, it wasn't, like, so fucking cold.
It snowed every day.
Like, I think that was the worst part for me.
Like, um, it did, for some reason, it wasn't as cold as I thought it was gonna be, um, for the fact that it was snowing.
I felt like it was more, it was colder in Canada, for sure, for me.
Um, but, like, it's just snow, no, it, like, we're, it's colder in Canada.
I feel colder in Canada, but, like, Sapporo snows every day, and it sucked for me because, like, I wanted to, like, explore and walk around.
I just took cabs every day because I, I couldn't, I could not walk outside in the snow.
It was, like, you would think it was, like, little snow, but, like, it was a lot.
And, like, the sidewalk, like, in Canada, we salt our, we salt the roads and the sidewalks and everything.
I think because it snows so much in Sapporo, they don't salt the roads a lot.
It's not, like, salted as normally because it snows way too much.
So, um, so, like, there was, like, areas where it was just snow, and I was, like, wow, wow, trying to make sure I don't fucking slip and kill myself, I guess, like, I was just, like, wow.
So then I gave up walking around and, like, I gave up walking around and I had to, I had to, like, get a cab.
And I was just, like, everywhere because I was, like, I need to go here.
And then it was just, it was rough.
It was very rough.
And then, because, like, okay, one time, one time, also, like, I bumped into one of the players on a date.
Because, you know, one of the days I didn't go watch, I didn't go watch the ALGS matches.
I was just, like, shopping time, wow!
So, well, it wasn't the players, it was, like, one of the staff members.
So, so, but it was funny, because I, like, snitched them out to the team.
Okay, I won't say which team, I won't say which team, but, like, it was so funny.
But, okay, so, like, I decided to, like, I was, I was gonna, I was not gonna go watch the game that day.
And then I was, like, I'm gonna go shopping, I'm gonna walk around and go shopping.
And, and then, so, I was walking around Sapporo, near where the players are.
So, like, there's, like, a players hotel.
And I was walking around, like, a district that was near the players hotel, because there's a lot of stuff there.
There's a lot of stories and stuff, and, like, I just wanted to walk around.
And I was, like, oh, I wanna go to the Village Vanguard and stuff, because there's a lot of, like, things I enjoy.
Like, you know, Village Vanguard has, like, a lot of, like, Village Vanguard is, like, Hot Topic, but in Japan, but a better version of Hot Topic.
Um, so, like, there was a lot more, like, you know, like, pop culture stuff and cute stuff going inside.
I need to, like, grab my water.
And, uh, so, like, uh, basically, the worst part was that, you know, it didn't seem like it was snowing.
So, I was, like, okay, I'm gonna take a cab to this spot, and I'm gonna walk around.
And then the moment I, like, you know, finished, uh, the moment I got, like, finished shopping at, uh, at a Village Vanguard, um, it started snowing.
And then I was, like, ah, fuck, okay, um, this is fucking awkward.
So then I was, like, okay, I'm gonna walk around a little bit and just see how I feel.
And I walked, I took, like, I literally walked, like, you know, across the street, and I was, like, it's over.
Like...
I was, like, I can't.
I can't do this.
I'm not strong enough.
So, um, I was, like, oh my gosh, I can't do this.
I can't.
I'm not strong enough.
And then I was just, like, it was just bad.
It was just snowing way too much.
Like, it was not, like, small snow.
It was, like, like, you know, like, it was a lot of snow while it was snowing down.
Like, I couldn't get my phone out and look at my phone because the snow would just cover my phone.
Like, or, like, it'd just make my phone all wet.
Like, just for, like, if I had my phone out for, like, five seconds, my entire phone would just be wet.
So I was just, like, it's so hot.
I was, like, oh, man, this is, uh, this is fucking rough.
It's, like, oh, man.
And then, so, um, so then the worst part was that very moment, because I was, like, I'm going to take an Uber.
I'm going to take an Uber back to my hotel and just be warm.
And then, but the worst part was that, um, um, the worst part was just the fact that that exact moment my data stopped working.
So I was, like, trying to find a place to, like, mooch off.
I don't know why.
It was just that exact moment.
I told you I was so unlucky during this entire trip.
Like, this exact moment, I just didn't have internet.
I just didn't have data.
I don't know why.
Like, it was working earlier.
It was working during, like, when I was shopping.
And then, like, suddenly, I just, when I went out in the snow, my data just stopped working.
And then I was just, like, oh, no.
Where is my internet?
Oh, no.
So, like, I found, like, this dessert place.
Like, I found, like, I was, like, I need to find a cafe or something to mooch off the internet so I can call an Uber.
And, um, and, like, I found this, like, cafe dessert place.
And then I went in.
I was, like, oh, this is cute.
And then they have internet.
So I was, like, yippee.
I was, like, okay, I'm gonna grab something small to eat.
And then, like, after I finish eating, I'm gonna call an Uber.
And this is where I accidentally stumbled upon a date.
So, okay, so, like, um, I didn't realize someone was on a date until, like, because they were on the other side.
I was, like, I wasn't, I didn't care.
Like, obviously, I wasn't, like, eavesdropping or anything because I was, like, too focused on, like, um, on, like, you know, on my phone and, like, eating my food.
And then I heard, and I was wearing my headphones, too.
And then I heard what the guy was, like, talking about eSports and, like, uh, Apex.
And, obviously, my ears perked up.
And I was, like, huh?
In English?
And, obviously, you know, it was a white guy in, like, in Japan.
So, like, you're more, you know, we're, like, what are you doing here?
You know, I can blend in because I'm Asian.
So, like, um, so it was, like, huh?
Hmm.
And then, but he was, like, on, uh, he was on a date with, like, a JP girl.
And then, I think it was, like, a JP Apex girl.
And then I was just, like, whoa.
And then, like, you know, I paid my, I paid my bill.
And, um, um, I paid my bill.
And then I walked past, not over to them, and be, like, hey, I know you, like, what are you guys talking about?
Like, I'm not that creepy.
But, like, okay.
And then, you know, I, like, like, I, like, you know, I finished eating.
And then, like, I got my Uber.
And then I left.
But then before I left, I, like, glanced over to be, like, maybe if I reckon, do I recognize this person?
Because, you know, I know, like, a lot of, like, Apex pro players.
And then I didn't sit next to him, I was on the other side.
I was on the other side.
And then, so, like, I, like, walked over just to see.
And then I saw them wearing a team sweater.
And then I was like, oh, my God, I won't say the team.
I won't say, I'm not gonna rat them out.
Like, I just thought it was a funny experience.
And then, like, I was like, oh, my God, wait.
Oh, my God, it is an Apex player.
Or, like, I don't know, an Apex player or an Apex staff.
I know it wasn't an Apex player, because I knew all the people on the team.
So then I was like, so then I messaged one of the team members.
And I was like, I think I bumped into one of your staff, like, going on a date.
Doki, you need to learn to mind your own business.
Oh, I'm sorry, I was curious, okay?
I was like, I was so curious, okay?
I was just like, whoa, oh, my God, gossip.
Okay, and then, snitch!
Okay, not in public, though.
Okay, I just thought it was funny.
I thought it was really funny.
And then, so, like, I messaged one of the team members, and I was like, I think I saw one of your staff members on a date.
And they're like, we can't be, and they're like, wait, what?
Like, they're talking about team members?
I was like, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm pretty sure it's one of your staff, because, like, I recognize your team members.
And they're like, oh, it can't be that guy, obviously.
And then they showed a picture, and I was like, oh, my God, that's him!
And then he was like, my friend was like, oh, my God, he's supposed to be at the booth right now, managing our merch store.
And I was like, are you sure?
I was like, oh, I'm pretty sure that was the guy I saw on the date.
I was like, I don't know, I'm pretty sure.
He was near the Players Hotel, and, like, the place I was at was near the Players Hotel, and that's supposed to be a secret.
And, like, I don't know, some tall white guy in Japan is sort of, like, hard to miss.
So he's like, are you sure?
And I was like, yeah, I'm pretty sure.
I just thought it was funny, I was like... I thought that was really funny, I was like...
How was I supposed to know he had responsibilities at the arena?
How the fuck was I supposed to know that?
I was like, oh my gosh, bro, I caught him on a date, bro!
And he's like, wait, he's supposed to be back at the arena right now.
Gas, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Wow, bro, at least scored.
I mean, I saw him pay for... okay, like, it sounds so bad, it feels like I was, like, watching them.
But literally when I was about... when I was leaving, I saw him pay for the meals.
And she seemed really happy, so I'm pretty sure he was in.
I'm pretty sure... I'm pretty sure he was in at that point.
You guys are like my diaries, like, dear diary, today I saw a bitch going on a date when he was supposed to be at the arena.
Anyway, I thought that was really funny.
Okay, so, like, the last day.
Okay, so I watched the last day, which was technically today.
And, like, I didn't do the opening ceremony for it because that was way too early.
I was like, I need to sleep.
I couldn't be bothered going to... I think, like, I showed up because it looked really cool.
Because I watched the opening ceremony on the... on, like, in my hotel room.
On my phone, I watched.
And I was just like, oh my gosh, it's way too early.
Like, I just couldn't be bothered.
Because I was like, okay, for those who don't know Apex LAN, Apex ALGS tournaments or esports.
Basically, there's no X amount of games.
It is called match point finals.
So what that means is that when a team hits 50 points, whichever team wins with 50, like, at the threshold of 50 points wins the whole entire thing.
But the thing is, it could take a very long time.
And like, I came in late, not like super late, but like, I like, I think, like, third game, like, by the end of third game, I was there.
And then like, oh my god, it was so long.
It was so long.
I was like, oh my god.
It went to, it was nine games.
It was, it was nine games.
I was like, and there were like, delays to apparently there was like an hour delay and everything.
Because like, PCs were not working.
They had people at the swap PCs and stuff like that.
At one point, it took like one hour to start game three.
So, so like, I waited until that delay was over before I went over.
Because I was like, I was like, bro, oh my god, when is this issue gonna be fixed?
I'm not coming over when they're still trying to fix PC issues.
So like, I, I was like, I waited until like game three got delayed for one hour at least.
Um, so I was just like, oh my gosh.
Oh, yeah, there's a there was a lot of like SSD issues, apparently, or like graphics card issues from what I've heard.
So at one point, um, um, I know like this happened to like several teams, but like, basically, like, teams were getting walls.
Like, like, oh my god, they're hacking.
But like, because like the SSD was failing, because they don't talk about it on obviously don't say on stream what it was, but like, I got the insider knowledge.
So like, the SSD was failing to the point where like, um, players ended up getting walls and stuff.
And like, like, so like, they could see everything and then they would, you know, they'll be like, I have walls.
So that's why like, some of them stopped the game because they're like, oh, fuck, like, bro, he got walls.
Um, so apparently, that happened several times.
And then assets weren't loaded yet.
Mike, there was like microphone issues and stuff like that from some teams as well.
And then just like graphics cards were failing and stuff like that.
So they had to swap it up.
Um, I know it's five days from now, but I think I've worked that day and I don't want to miss it.
Happy anniversary, Doki.
Thank you, the super chat's upside down.
Thank you, thank you.
So like, that, um, yeah, that's crazy that it happened in LAN too.
Like, that's actually like the probability of that happening in LAN several times too.
Apparently, like, um, I heard that like, cause there was a biggest issue with like, um, I think like it was NIG where like, I think it was Fun had, um, basically, uh, they had, they kicked him out on the first time that happened.
And then the second time they let them back in.
But it happened to that specific bug happened to him twice on two different PCs, which is so fucked if you think about it.
Like, I was like, how does that happen twice to the same person on different days?
Yeah.
I was like, Oh my God.
The first time it happened, they just kicked him out.
Like, cause they're like, well, you have walls and the PC crashed.
And then the second time they're like, okay, that's weird.
All right.
We're just gonna try and let you back in.
Yeah.
So, um, that's crazy.
The fact that like, that guy got like two different PCs on two different days and it still happened was like, what kind of luck do you have to have that happen?
And, um, and then apparently during like the one hour delay, like it was like POIs where they gave wrong POIs, PCs were not working.
So they were restarting it over and over and over again.
And because like teams were also experiencing the walls glitch as well, like getting walls and stuff and, um, assets disappeared.
Like, and then like, but obviously at that time during the third game, during finals, they fixed all that issue.
And then like, there wasn't any intermission and pauses anymore.
Thank fucking God.
Cause like, I was slowly, I was, I was slowly having my life sucked away from me watching that, watching nine games.
Like I didn't even watch nine games cause I showed up after game three.
Um, I showed up after game three.
So I was having my life sucked out after game three.
So like at first I was like, whoa, yeah, baby.
And then, you know, it got to game five.
I was like, whoa, baby.
That's what's getting along.
And then we had to scheme sounds like, oh, okay.
Whoa.
Okay.
And then game eight.
I'm like, oh my God.
Match point finals.
So stupid.
I think it's not going to lie.
I feel like it's more exciting if you're watching from home with match point finals, but like, I don't know.
It was just, that's why I was like, um, um, that's all.
I was just like, oh man.
Like for me, I was like, maybe that's not for me because I feel like for others be like, yeah, match point finals.
It's so exciting.
But like for me, I was just like, I used to be like, oh my God, more tournaments to do match point finals.
But like, I think if I was there since the more, like since game one, I'd be so fucking dead.
I'd be like so fucking dead by game nine.
I was just like, oh my God.
I was just like, oh shit.
Maybe I think I just need, I think also like now I know what it's like watching LAN, like, you know, by myself versus I maybe I need to experience it.
Cause someone's like, oh yeah, I experienced watching LAN with friends.
And the thing is, the problem is that all my friends at LAN are like famous.
So I was worried.
Cause I was like, okay.
So I was trying to like, I tried to like meet up with like, okay.
So one of the people I tried to meet up with was, um, um, was Effect.
But like, I was just like, oh man, like, I was just like, bro, I can't.
You're like, Alliance is like so fucking famous in Japan.
It's actually crazy.
Um, there's so many like Alliance fangirls.
Like I was like, oh my, okay.
So like one of the, one of the people I sat next to during like one of those days and, um, I never got a chance to meet Effect because like we just kept missing each other.
And like, I was going to do like, I was like, okay, like obviously I cannot meet you in a public place.
You're taking, you're getting photos.
Like I would like bump, like I wouldn't bump into them, but I would like pass them by and stuff.
And then like, I just see them getting mobbed every time.
So, so like they would like go out and then they would go to like the public area and then people would like ask for photos and stuff like that.
So I saw that.
I was like, I can't do that.
Like that's, that's way too crazy.
So, um, and so like, no, but it's crazy.
Okay.
So like some, okay.
So I sat next to a group of Alliance fangirls and like, um, they were like super passionate and then like, but I think they were all there for unlucky.
And then I, because how do I know?
Because I looked over cause they were like super passionate about Alliance.
So I looked over and then like their phone wallpapers was just unlucky.
Like, you know, like idols and stuff like they're basically idols to like, I think in Japan.
Um, so like, and then like, um, so I was like, whoa, okay.
Yeah.
Like there was a, there's a guy, uh, in the guys, like he has got to have no kids.
So like, um, he's single too, by the way, ladies and men, he is single.
So, um, so, um, so like, yeah.
Um, um, and he's a roller player.
Yeah.
So, um, um, anyway, anyway, I thought it was like, I thought it was really cute.
Like they were like super passionate.
It was super cute.
And so like, I was like, okay.
And then I was going to do like something really stupid.
I didn't do it because I was like, uh, and then like, if I was like, oh yeah, we had like an unofficial meeting.
And I was like, oh shit.
Okay.
And then like my gears were turning.
I was like, where is it?
Cause I was going to be like, pretend to be a fan.
And then like afterwards, just be like, haha, you actually met me.
And then, but like, I would not say anything until like, I wanted to like, you know, like be like, oh, that's right.
That random person you met in that giant meet and greet, it was me.
I was going to do that cause I thought it was super funny.
Um, and then like, but then he gave me the wrong fucking instructions.
Uh, it was me, Barry.
So I was going to do that.
Um, and, uh, I couldn't because I was like, where the fuck is this unofficial meet and greet?
And then he was like, oh, it's like in the main entrance.
And I was like, all right.
And then like, I was walking around and I was like, where the fuck is this?
Like, cause I wanted to get there early cause I knew it was going to get like, um, it was going to be like a lot of people.
And then, um, no, I would put on a voice.
Like I would always put on a voice for it.
Uh, so like people won't like recognize.
Anyway, so, um, I also didn't talk a lot cause I thought I was scared.
Um, anyway, so, and then, but I saw Timmy's line.
Oh my God.
Timmy's line was fucking crazy.
I'll show you guys pictures when I'm back.
Like I took a picture of the line.
I just took four, I took three different photos to illustrate how long Timmy's line was.
It's Timmy's line, it's Timmy.
He wasn't even playing in the champs.
He wasn't even playing in champs.
I was like, how the fuck?
He got, his team got fucking knocked out.
Like, so, so like, like, okay.
So his line was like, if, if I, I needed to take four to five photos to illustrate how long his line was.
I took three.
I literally was like, there's one of the, here's one set.
There's another set and there's Timmy.
I could have taken two more photos to illustrate how long his line was.
And I was like, thinking in my head, they don't know.
Timmy once raided me for Marvel Rivals and I played with him before.
And it was the most embarrassing moment when I played with him because I wasn't listening.
Those people don't know that.
And I saw him in the player lounge.
I didn't do anything about it though.
I just saw him.
Press Q.
Yeah, anyway.
So there were so many lines.
There were so many fucking lines.
Oh my God.
I was going to go crazy at the amount of lines.
Anyway, so the secret, I felt like a stalker at that point.
So like, there was that.
And okay.
So anyway, so anyway, I was like, the fuck?
And then like, I was like, where the fuck is this?
Unofficial meet and greet.
And then when Effect said main entrance, it was actually outside.
I was like, oh my God, the most critical information I did not receive.
I literally waited in the arena for like, at least 30 minutes.
Because I was like, where the fuck?
Where is this?
And then like, I went out.
And then obviously, I see the alliance meet and greet.
It was so fucking long.
It was like, it was just like a circle of people.
It was like, there was so many people there.
I was like, oh my God, I am not.
I'm not gonna.
I'm not.
I'm sorry, bro.
I'm sorry.
It was, I'm not doing that.
I'm not lining up in the fucking cord.
So it wasn't even the main entrance.
It was outside, and you gotta walk a little bit off of the main entrance.
And then, because it was where the ice sculptures were.
And like, the ice sculptures were like, you gotta walk like, at least one to two minutes to get there.
It's not even the main entrance.
I was like, you could have said outside.
You could have said, the ice sculptures, you know?
Like, oh my God.
And then I went there, and I was just like, Jesus fucking Christ, this is a mob.
So I was like, fuck it, peace, I'm out.
I'm going back.
I'm getting dinner.
I was just like, fucking peace.
I like, snapped a photo of like, his back.
I was like, I tried my best.
This is the closest I could get.
And then I sent it over.
I sent it over.
By the way, if you guys didn't know, Effect is a dragon.
And then like, I sent it over.
And then I was just like, this is the closest I could get.
Like, fuck you, man.
And it's like, no!
And then Effect, like, messaged back after the meeting, he's like, no!
I literally sent a picture of like, I took a picture of like, the fucking back, his back.
And like, with a fan.
And I was like, here you go.
Yeah, so, now I look like this.
You should have been more specific!
Oh my god.
You could have had an unofficial meet and greet with DokiBrit.
Actually, he wouldn't have known.
I would have been like, oh!
One of those fans you met was me!
I was gonna do that anyway.
So like, you wouldn't have...
It wouldn't have won either way for him.
Cause I wasn't even gonna tell him.
Anyway...
But which one?
Anyway, so like...
So like, okay.
So yeah, like, match point final.
Oh my gosh.
It was just...
By the way, it was so funny.
Because like, I had a friend who was like...
I had some friends that was like, watching it on like, obviously at home.
They weren't in Sapporo.
So then, for those who don't know, like, the team that won the finals was the team that nobody recognized.
Like, not nobody.
Like, no one was like...
No one knew it was gonna win the tournament.
Cause it was match point final.
They literally just need to win first place after hitting 50 points.
That's all they have to do.
So like, anyway.
Thundercat, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Today is my birthday!
Can I get happy...
Of course!
You can get a birthday wish from me.
And it's your very first super chat too!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Thunder.
Yeah!
Anyway...
Anyway, they were sort of like, the underdogs.
So like...
Not gonna lie, when they won...
I was like...
Who?
I'm so sorry!
And then my friend also texted...
My friend who was live watching it at home was like...
Who the fuck just won?
I was just like...
I had my phone and I googled.
I was like...
Oh, they're EU.
And then my friend was like...
Oh my god, that makes sense.
I was just like...
I'm sorry!
I legitimately was like...
Who's to go next?
I was like, look at the players.
And I was like...
Oh, it's EU.
Okay, then.
I'm sorry, EU.
I was like...
Legitimately...
I was just like...
Yeah, I was just like...
Oh, no wonder.
No wonder I didn't know who they were.
Because like...
EU...
EU is...
There's only two teams that people know from EU.
And I think it's Aurora and Alliance.
So like...
Any other team is like...
People are like...
Who?
Oh, yeah.
I'm happy.
I was like...
World of Falcons.
Die.
Please.
You won too many.
Oh, were there two rats?
Wait, was that two rats?
Okay, one controller.
Oh my god.
Okay, I remember them now.
You see, if they had that name...
I would remember them.
I didn't know that was TwoRatsOneController.
Oh, now the memories are flooding back.
See, TwoRatsOneController was memorable.
GoNext is not.
Even though I know it's because...
You know, they got into an org and they have to be GoNext now.
But still, TwoRatsOneController was a very good name.
But yeah, so...
I guess that was...
That was my LAN experience.
Like, I just...
It's just dragged on for so long.
That like...
I just...
I couldn't sit for that long.
I think it's just I was watching it alone and stuff.
Mostly, other than my friends texting me.
I didn't get to experience watching this with friends and stuff.
And I think that was the reason why I didn't enjoy LAN as much as I did.
I think if I was watching with friends...
I think it sucked because I had to be incognito mode too.
Because I got a tweet reply.
They're like, I knew that was you when you were with Tempo.
And I was like, I did not meet up with Tempo.
We kept missing each other.
He walked past me.
But he walked past so fast, I couldn't even say hi.
And then I was like, Oh, that was not me.
That was not me.
They're like, Oh my god, I saw you with Tempo, but I felt weird to intrude.
And I was like, Oh man, if you intrude, you would find out that that was definitely not me.
Because I was like, I was not there.
I was not there with Tempo.
So I thought that was really funny.
I felt like if people thought I was with Tempo...
I don't even know who the fuck that random girl was that was with him.
But I'm now thinking that people randomly went up to Tempo and be like, Oh my god, is that Doki Bird?
And then the poor woman is going to be like, Who the fuck is she?
Yeah, so the only times I could meet people was literally outside the arena.
Because I couldn't trust people.
Because every time the pro players or the people I know were outside, were in a public area where there's fans there, it was just pictures being taken and stuff.
And then people coming up to them and being like, Oh my god, we'll sign this.
And I was just like, I'm backing out.
I'm not getting involved here.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It was Negaverse, Doki, and if he had stopped her, her double copy would have stolen his wallet and also his eternal soul.
Thank you for the super chat, Fuzzy.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, and I got so anxious too.
I was like, oh, do they know?
I was super fucking anxious.
I was like, oh, they don't know I'm Doki Bird.
Or do they?
That's how I felt during the time in the arena.
I was like, they don't know.
Or do they?
Or do they know?
Oh my god, okay.
And then there were so many lines.
Okay, I had to wait for lines for a cab.
And then I had to wait.
Oh my god, there were so many lines.
Oh my god, I can't fucking...
There's a reason why I kept leaving before the game's end.
And then like, the champs was the one time I stayed the entire time.
But there were so many people that needed to take the cab.
I felt like I was...
I waited for a cab for like an hour and a half.
Like almost an hour and a half waiting for a cab to go eat dinner.
Because I was like, you know, I could have just taken...
I should have just taken the subway.
I'm so stupid.
I was just like, I'm already in too deep.
I was like, when I got to like 30 minutes, I was just like, I'm already lining up.
I might as well stay for the rest of the line.
And then, you know, it hit 40 to 50 minutes.
I was like, oh, I'm already in too deep.
I'm already in too deep.
So, yeah.
Okay.
Also, I wrote some notes down during this trip.
Because like, you know, I like to write notes down when I'm traveling just for stories and stuff.
But the games were so long during champs finals that some guys in front of me were fucking playing gacha games.
And I was just like, I'm looking in front of me and some guys on their phones were like literally pulling for gacha.
Or like doing their rolls and stuff.
And I was just like, dailies and stuff.
And I was like, you know what?
Understandable.
Like, valid.
Like, because it was like, we were at game fucking eight.
Okay, like, I was like, that's valid.
That's fucking valid, buddy.
That's so valid.
Gotta do the dailies.
Yeah.
Like, oh my god.
Just to watch nine games for teams to not win.
Like, I'm tired.
It's loud.
I had a headache too.
I had to put on like my earphones at one point.
Like during half of the games.
Because it was so loud.
And like, I took videos by the way.
The stadium was packed.
Like, this is the background of my photo.
That's basically like, it was sold out.
Like 20,000 people apparently in the stadium.
And like, I had to put like earphones in.
So like, just to dampen the sound.
Because it was so loud.
Because I got a headache.
Or was it 30k?
Oh my god, that's even more.
I thought it was 20k.
Spreading misinformation.
What else is new?
But I don't know how many people the stadium allows.
But it was around, it was like 20 to 30k.
It was sold out by the way.
Well, not for me.
Because I had the special guest pass.
I could go.
So like, by the way.
I forgot to bring my guest pass.
And then I like, because there's like a special line to go in.
For like people with like the special passes.
And then I was like, I forgot to bring my pass.
Can I have another one?
But I'm on the list.
I'm on the list.
I'm somebody.
And then they're like, yeah, of course.
But you gotta return it the next day.
I didn't return it.
So now I have two passes.
It has my name on it!
It doesn't matter.
They can't reuse it.
It has my name on it.
What are they gonna do?
It was just gonna be garbage anyway.
You rebel.
Yay!
Now I have two passes.
I didn't do it intentionally.
I just forgot to return it.
Okay, guys.
I legitimately did not do it intentionally.
I just forgot.
And I was like, well, it's the last day.
I can't bring it back now.
I was just like, what am I gonna do?
Bring it back?
It's the last day.
I can't.
There's no tomorrow.
I just forgot.
It's different.
There was another thing that was super unlucky.
I'm reading back the notes.
I wrote a lot of notes.
I don't know if you guys know.
I was gonna tell this when I'm back, but I'll tell you guys this now.
The Tokyo airport has to be the most fucking confusing shit ever.
If you have a transfer flight, it is so...
If you guys didn't know this, usually you would think that they would...
People instantly knew which airport it was.
They're like, this one?
Yeah.
So basically, if you guys didn't know, when you transfer, usually your luggage goes to the next plane, right?
Yeah, usually that should be it.
Your luggage would just... you don't have to do anything about it.
That's usually how it goes.
But when you land in Japan, you have to pick up your luggage.
And then you gotta go to a different fucking terminal.
And then you gotta check in.
You gotta check in that luggage again.
So the issue was that I was like, where the fuck am I?
Oh my god.
Yeah, so like...
So you have to go through...
You have to basically grab your luggage and fucking...
Oh my god.
No, but they transfer your luggage to a different... usually transfer it to a different plane.
Anyway.
Anyway, so like, I went there.
And then I had to transfer it to...
I was so fucking...
The thing is...
I had such a short window to do all of that, that I had to be booked at the next flight.
Because when we arrived, we had a small delay on my flight.
So when I arrived, they were like, you're gonna miss this flight, I'm sorry.
I was just like, whoa.
The amount of time I had to get my fucking luggage.
And then...
And take it to a different flight.
I was not gonna make it.
So I didn't have to pay for the new hour.
I was like, thank god it was just an hour later.
Because I was like, I was gonna go crazy.
I was gonna go fucking crazy if it got delayed.
Because I was so tired.
But basically, they were like, yeah, it's okay.
The next flight is an hour.
And then...
But then I was like, where the fuck am I?
They don't write this down for you, by the way.
They don't give you a sheet that has all the information.
It was basically like, they just tell you and then you just gotta remember.
So they were like, you gotta go to Terminal 2.
I was in Terminal 3, by the way.
Because I was like, what terminal am I in?
When I got out, I was just like, where am I?
What terminal am I in?
Where do I go?
And I had to take a bus.
I was like, where's the bus?
And then like, you gotta get out of the terminal and get to a bus.
And then like, where's the bus?
Where is it?
And you get to the bus.
And you gotta wait two stops because it goes to Terminal 1 first.
And then Terminal 2.
And then you gotta find the airline where your next flight is.
And then I was just like, where the fuck am I?
Holy shit.
And also, everything closes so early.
This airport is already closed.
And then, obviously...
And then like, oh my god, I didn't realize how fucking...
And then, one of my biggest gripes is that like...
I love Japan because they're all like, you know, technology and like, they're super...
What's it called?
They're very like, orderly and like, bureaucracy and stuff like that.
And like, they're very to the point.
And oh my god, what's the word I'm looking for?
Efficient.
But sometimes, they're so efficient that it's inefficient.
And I will tell you one of the things that made me so...
Like, I was gonna freak out because I was tired.
So like, I forgot...
The one thing I forgot was...
The one thing I forgot was that I forgot to bring coins.
I forgot to get currency.
Because like, I was like, I'm just...
I don't know why.
I felt like I was like, prepared but also not prepared at the same time.
So I forgot to bring currency.
So I was really thirsty.
So I was like, there's a vending machine, right?
And then I was like, oh man, I don't have cash on me.
But I do have Apple Pay and my card.
So like, I thought, you know, like normally, you just beep the card.
And then you get your drink.
But then like, I was so confused.
Because I was like, why isn't this working?
It clearly has a card reader.
And I was like, beep, beep.
So like, I was like, that's so weird.
And I tried my Apple Pay.
I was like, maybe it's my card not working.
And I was like, I was thirsty.
I was thirsty as hell.
I was like, beep, beep.
Okay, not working.
And the lady next to me was doing the same thing.
So then I was like, oh my god, what am I doing wrong?
Apparently, so on the card reader, there were symbols on the top.
There were symbols of what kind of card you're supposed to, you can use.
And you're supposed to press the symbol of the card that you're using.
But it was not clear.
I...
Because it was, they all glow.
I didn't realize you have to select the exact card you're using.
But like, everything glowed.
So I didn't realize that like, there was no instructions.
There was no instructions.
Like, even if there was, I would have fucking got my Google Translate and translated that.
Like...
And so, I was just like, I was just like, I can't.
I was like, I figured, because I was like, oh my gosh, like, I was just like, am I stupid?
Like...
I was like, but the lady beside me was also so fucking confused.
She didn't understand too.
Like...
And so, yeah, and so then I was just like, I was just like, because like, I was desperate.
I was like, okay, whatever.
I was like, oh my gosh, this is my last ditch effort.
Like, am I supposed to press these symbols?
Like, because it doesn't look like you could press them.
That was the thing.
It didn't look like I could press them.
So I was just like, oh my God, like, but I was just like, maybe I can press them.
I was like...
I was like, oh my God, maybe, like, you can actually press this.
And I pressed it, and then it, like, you know, it, like, sparkled.
Like...
It, like, you know, glowed in and out.
I was like, oh my fucking God.
I had to deal with puzzles in real life.
I was like, oh my God.
Oh my God, I can actually get water.
Oh my God.
And then it blew my mind.
I was like, that's so dumb.
Holy shit, why wasn't this automatic?
Why did I have to personally select the symbol?
I was so confused.
I was so...
Oh my God, where is my yellow paint?
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Anyway, so that was, like, that was my sad moment.
That, like, I was...
That was my fucking sad moment there.
Oh my God.
Anyway, so, there was that.
And then...
Yeah, it didn't give me any hints.
It was just like, you just gotta deal with it.
You gotta figure this out yourself, Doki.
Oh my God, Professor Lin actually trained me for this.
Anyway, so...
Okay, so people were like, food poisoning.
There really isn't much of a story.
I don't know what the fuck I ate in Japan.
I legitimately don't know.
Like, I cannot figure this out.
Like, it could have been anything.
It really could.
Like, out of all the places I had to get food poisoning, it was Japan, which is crazy to think about.
Because, like, I don't know how.
Literally, just like, I ate food.
I ate lunch.
I, like, lunch, and dessert, and dinner.
And then, went to bed at 7.
I woke up, and I was not alive anymore.
I was not a person anymore.
I was just, I used the bathroom, and I was like, my stomach was not feeling good.
And I was like, oh.
And then, I was like, used the bathroom.
I was like, oh my gosh.
Okay, I'm definitely, I ate something wrong.
And then, my stomach was still like, ooh, it doesn't feel so good.
So then, I went back to the bathroom.
And then, I was like, am I gonna throw up?
I did.
I looked at the toilet.
I was like, am I gonna throw up?
And then, it happened.
And I was like, oh.
And then, yeah, and then like, because I was like, okay, I could feel something in my stomach.
And it wants to come out of my mouth hole, not the other hole.
And then, I was just like, okay.
I definitely ate something wrong.
I definitely.
And then, so like, and then, so I was basically, I was living in the bathroom and also the bed for like, until like, for 24 hours.
And then, like, I couldn't keep water down.
I legitimately, like, I would drink water.
And like, I was throwing up water too.
So, it was bad.
I don't know how the fuck I survived.
And I told, like, some of my friends about it.
Like, you know, after the, like, today, I was just like, yeah, I got food poisoning.
And then, they were like, oh, man, you should, like, be careful what you're eating.
Like, because, you know, like, you might feel okay.
And then, like, but, like, for dinner, because I didn't eat lunch at all.
I didn't even eat lunch because, like, when I woke up, like, today, I didn't even eat lunch.
I ate nothing.
Like, I think my, I wasn't even hungry though.
Like, um, I wasn't even hungry at all.
No, I couldn't hold water down.
It was actually water.
Because I would drink water and I would throw up water.
Um, so, like, I literally could just quit and keep eating.
Like, I would drink Pocari Sweat.
Because, like, I was reading that you should get electrolytes too.
And then, like, I couldn't even keep, like, Pocari Sweat in.
Because I was throwing up the Pocari Sweat too.
I could tell I was throwing up the Pocari Sweat.
Oh, that's disgusting.
I'm sorry.
TMI.
But, like, I had to give you that information.
Like, it was not okay.
Like, ew.
It was not okay.
And then, so, like, um, so, um, anyway.
Uh, not TMI.
Thank you for sharing.
And, um, anyway.
Um, so, like, um, so, like, my friends, they're, like, telling me, like, oh, yeah.
It's the day after your food poisoning.
Because I was like, I feel great now.
I think I got it out of my system.
And my friends, they were, like, telling me.
Because I was like, I'm gonna grab dinner.
And they're like, oh, you should be careful.
You should eat something light.
You should maybe get soup.
Maybe miso soup.
And I was like, I don't care.
I'm gonna eat something good.
I was like, no.
I'm fucking going at it.
Anyway, I had a great dinner.
I got pasta.
No, I'm okay.
Surprisingly, I'm invincible.
Surprisingly, I'm okay for now.
I don't know.
Maybe later.
Goodbye, pasta.
But, like, they're, like, just, like, you should really, like, make sure you eat slow.
And make sure, like, maybe don't eat something too much.
Like, you know, eat something light.
And, like, maybe get some soup.
And I was like, no.
I'm gonna eat something good.
I haven't eaten anything in so long.
Swarm, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
When you feel under the weather, drink bran.
It got electrolytes.
It's what plants crave.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway, I had pasta.
Carbonara pasta, too.
In Japan.
I really, I love, like, Japanese pasta.
It's, like, there's, like, a way they make pasta that's, like, I don't know.
It's just different.
Like, Japanese pasta, the way they make it is different from, like, the way...
It's different from, like, you know, N.A.
pasta.
So, I was, like, I was looking forward to it.
And, anyway.
Yeah, I live on the edge.
I might have just had food poisoning literally 24 hours ago.
But I got this.
You only live one.
It was the one.
That was why.
I don't know why the fuck I did that.
Bless your heart.
Really, I'm proud.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I have no idea why the fuck I risked my life for that pasta.
I could have got curry, too.
I was thinking, I was like, wow, do I get curry?
But then the line was too long.
So, I was like, pasta it is.
Alright, guys.
I did say today was gonna be a short stream.
I'm sorry, guys.
I gotta...
I'm gonna call it here.
Oh, my God.
I've been yapping for an hour.
I missed you guys.
I missed you guys, Dragoons.
It's been a while.
And, like...
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, yeah.
By the way, here's a little tidbit.
There was an after party for...
I don't know if I'm supposed...
I feel like the players would talk about it.
There's an after party for, like, LGS.
For, like, players and, like, coaches and staff.
They're allowed to bring a plus one.
And then I was like, nah.
Because I wanted to...
I wanted to sleep.
But, like...
Also, like, I got paranoid.
Because I knew people were gonna take pictures in the after party.
And then...
But the thing is...
The after party was in a red light district.
And I was like, whoa!
Oh, my God.
I found out they fucking hosted...
They're hosting it at a red light district.
I was like...
I was like, holy fuck!
Wow, some of those players are getting some action today!
Oh, my God.
I was like, that's fucking crazy!
I was like, oh, my God!
Because one of my friends texted me.
They're like, I'm fucking leaving.
They're like, this is a red light district.
Oh, my God.
I'm so...
Because they're like an introvert.
One of my friends who's a player is an introvert.
And then he was like, bro, I can't.
I'm leaving.
There's too much.
I was just like...
I was like, I'm scared.
I was like, oh, my God!
Anyway, guys.
I'm going to head off now.
I'm going to sleep.
It's so late.
Anyway, guys.
As always, I hope I'll be back soon.
I'll be back very soon.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Oh, my gosh.
Give me a sec.
I realize I have no ending screen, so it's just going to be like...
It's going to cut off.
I can't do it, because...
Oh, my God.
I can't end the stream, because my goal line thing is...
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
All right.
It's just going to be like...
It just ends.
All right.
See you, guys.
This is where it's going to end.
All right, guys.
Bye.